I started to think of doing mathematics
in the last one year before last of high
school and so I was already 15 or
something when I realized that I was
enjoying solving problems that were
resisting you know that were a little
harder than usual and I had to think and
absorb myself and then and forget about
everything else and would come back with
a solution and one time I found our
solution I was rather creative and I
remember the teacher was surprised when
she when I presented my solution and I
think this is really when it clicked for
me that I would like to try to do
research in mass just because I was
enjoying the process and yeah you did I
don't see myself as a prodigy or a
genius at all I mean there are geniuses
out there but the geniuses are the
exception rather than the norm even
within the profession genius is kind of
like a god-given thing right you have it
or you don't have it I prefer to think
of ability or talent which is something
that can be cultivated and built up with
with hard work and I think certainly you
don't have to be a genius to become a
mathematician and to do interesting
mathematics it's it's more a question of
ability and having the taste and the
stamina to to do it you know being
willing to put in the hard work in and
enjoying the the process of the research
having the right frame of mind the right
mindset for